well now the establishment and legacy
media because they believe that they are
the sole expositors of truth they have
decided they are going to
curb social media they're going to
attack social media until social media
refuses to allow you to see the stuff
you went on facebook to see in the first
place
and facebook because now apparently
they're they're
being controlled from the inside by
their woke staffers and craven politicos
now because of that you're starting to
see social media curb their own
your ability to access the information
you went there to see in the first place
and they're doing so at the behest
of a pathetic self-indulgent media
firmly convinced of their own virtue
we're gonna get to more of this
in just one second this is what it's
gonna be like for years by the way it's
gonna be like this for years
this is the battle i've been saying this
for months now this is the battle it's
been obviously the battle since the
hunter biden shut down
this is the battle will you even get to
see will you even get to access the
information you want to see
will you be able to fight back against
the misinformation put out by the left
if the left controls all the sources of
informational dissemination okay so the
media's goal here is now to re-establish
their dominance
top down because the social media
companies they took you in they said
that you had a platform now where you
could see stuff that was not the
mainstream media again the mainstream
media dominated the space
they didn't need the social media
companies the social media companies
were explicitly
an alternative to those mainstream media
companies now the mainstream media
legacy media companies they're
attempting to use social media in order
to shut down the debate again
right they drew you in and now they are
shutting the door they're shutting the
door and they're making sure that you
don't see anything that they don't want
you to see
and they are laundering their
information in order to do so so what
they have basically declared
is that facebook for example should shut
down any right-wing site
so the way they do this is they actually
just go in very often and they falsify
information
people on the left will just go in and
falsify information so what they'll do
is they'll do things like this they'll
go to
newsguard which is a pathetic site which
is designed to
basically say that anybody on the right
is disinformation if you say you're
overtly conservative they say that you
are
not a trusted news source if you are if
you're a covertly
leftist right if you're the new york
times and you're pretty overtly leftist
but you try to pretend that you're not
then you're a trusted news source if
you're the daily wire and we just say
we're conservative
newsguard will literally say to us that
we are not a trusted news source because
we are more honest about our own
political biases
than the new york times and so newsguard
will then be used by facebook
in order to shut down our traffic you
will see that you will see people on the
left
suggest that we at the daily wear were
disinformation why well they'll go over
to
wikipedia and they will actually use a
sentence in our wikipedia profile
inserted by a partisan leftist that does
not reflect reality in any way
right right now the wikipedia profile
literally reads many of the website's
story involve unverified information and
maybe considered fake news they then
link to a story that does not say
anything like that
there is nothing in the story that even
alleges that doesn't matter and so
before the election this is not a shock
and here they are here are your
journalistic tech activists okay they
are not journalists they are activists
they are the the tip of the spear in
terms of trying to get
social media to shut down dissemination
of all information that doesn't come
from the new york times
kevin roose who spends every day trying
to get
facebook to shut down traffic to places
like daily wire or the federalist or
breitbart or
the blaze or any place that he disagrees
with
he has a piece today with mike isaac and
shira frankel saying facebook struggles
to balance civility
and growth civility and growth by
civility they mean
that they just want you not to be able
to see any information that is not from
the new york times
in the 10 days after the presidential
election a team of facebook employees
presented the chief executive mark
zuckerberg with an alarming finding
election-related misinformation was
going viral on the site
president trump was already casting the
election as rigged stories from
right-wing media outlets with false and
misleading claims about discarded
ballots
miscounted votes and skewed tallies were
among the most popular news stories on
the platform now
notes the reason that a lot of those
stories were popular on the platform is
because the new york times refused to
report many of them and a lot of them
were true kevin roose himself has said
this hey we reported
election irregularities in michigan okay
and it was a true story
kevin ruth suggested that it was a false
story openly on twitter and now he's
writing a story about how facebook needs
to shut down
those sorts of stories even though he
acknowledged the story was true on
twitter
the employees proposed an emergency
change to the news to the site's news
feed algorithm
which helps determine what more than 2
billion people see every day
it involves emphasizing the importance
of what facebook calls news ecosystem
quality scores or neq
a secret internal ranking it assigns to
news publishers based on signals about
the quality of their journalism
typically neq scores play a minor role
in determining what appears on user
feeds but several days after the
election
zuckerberg agreed to increase the weight
that facebook's algorithm gave to any q
scores to make sure authoritative news
appeared more prominently
said three people with knowledge of the
decision who were authorized not to
discuss
internal deliberations the change was
part of the break glass plans facebook
had spent months developing for the
aftermath of a contested election
it resulted in wait for it wait for it
wait for it a spike invisibility for big
mainstream publishers like cnn the new
york times and npr
while posts from highly engaged hyper
partisan pages such as breitbart and
occupy democrats became less visible
the employees said it was a vision of
what a calmer less divisive facebook
might look like
some employees argued the change should
become permanent even if it was unclear
how that might affect the amount of time
people spent
on facebook in an employee meeting the
week after the election workers asked
whether the nicer news feed could stay
said two people who attended first of
all zuckerberg is in control of his
company or if he is control
maybe he's not if he is control of his
company this would be about the damn
time for him to turn to his employees
and say why do i care what you think of
the nicer news algorithm
you are not the great arbiter of what
truth constitutes and by the way
for the new york times to say that their
program that they've been pushing
results in a spike in visibility for
them means they boosted their own
traffic
by basically hijacking the levers of
power at facebook via their staffers
cnn the new york times and npr all
massive publications
with huge 100 million dollar budgets all
of them got bigger
meanwhile any alternative source of
information was blocked
shocker shocker guy rosen a facebook
executive said that the plan was meant
to be temporary
but apparently there are many people on
facebook who want to see it
not be temporary instead they would like
to see facebook continue
to boost only information that they like
and denigrate all of the information
that they don't like
this is all part of the plan for the
radical
journalistic left they pretend they are
objective if you don't agree with them
it's because you're bad
and the social media feeds should only
reflect real news like the new york
times
and npr and cnn give me an effing break
and that's what you're gonna be dealing
with under a biden administration a
media the praetorian guard
for joe biden the praetorian guard for
democrats every republican will be
castigated
as evil and malevolent and satanic that
is where all of this is going
so get ready the lid is going to clamp
down on your ability to get information
that's why you should go subscribe to
your favorite publications right now
before it is too late
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button